السلام عليكم السلام عليكم
لقد تم طردنا من الجنه هكذا اعلنها
الاوروبيون والسبب روسيا موسكو تكشف تورط
واشنطن في تفجير انابيب الغاز وتطالب بقمه
طارئه
لحلفا تعاقب دوله عربيه بسبب دعمها لروسيا
وبريطانيا تضع خطه للحرب الاوكرانيه
والجيش الخفي لبوتين يخترق موقع حلف شمال
الاطلسي مخازن اسلحه الغرب تنفد وتحذيرات
روسيه بولندا هي التاليه بعد اوكرانيا
الولايات المتحده تغلق مجالها الجوي وبكين
تكسر صمتها لتحرك واشنطن قواتها الضاربه
في بحر الصين الجنوبي واما جارتها اليابان
ها هي تنشر اسلحه في حدود روسيا لياتيها
الرد سريعا من توتين وفي تركيا وسوريا
رائحه الموت تنتشر وعداد الموتى لا يتوقف
تجعل القلب يقطر دما
روسيا توسع اهدافها باتجاه الميتون مع مضي
الايام الحرب الاوكرانيه تتعقد اكثر فاكثر
والاوضاع تسوء بشكل لا يصدق لتعلنها
اوروبا بصوت عال لقد اصبحنا في الجحيم نعم
لقد قالها وزير الخارجيه النمساويه
بان بدء العمليه الروسيه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا يعتبر بمثابه طرد الاوروبيين من
الجنه هنا تبدا البوصله الروسيه بتغيير
مسارها لتنحرف نحو بولندا ولكن لماذا
الاجابه بسيطه حيث صرح رئيس الوزراء
البولندي ماتريوسكي بان بلاده نقلت 250
دبابه من طراز التيسنتيتو الى اوكرانيا
وسترسل في القريب العاجل 60 دبابه اضافيه
من طراز تي 72
الى الاوكرانيين اليكم المصدر في غضون ذلك
ذكرت وسائل اعلاما بولنديه انوار
وسبعين اضافه الى عشرات العربات المدرعه
لياتي الرد الروسي على لسان السيناتور عن
جمهوريه القرم الروسيه اوجا والتي قالت ان
الولايات المتحده تستخدم بولندا كورقه
مساومه وستصبح البديل الاوكراني في الحلقه
المناهضه لروسيا لكن المساعدات قد لا تنفع
بعد اليوم حيث صرح وزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق مع كاسبر بان الاوان قد فات على
تسليم اوكرانيا انظمه للدفاع الجوي
باوكرانيا كانت بحاجه اليها قبل عده اشهر
بحسب تعبيره وماذا عن الدبابات يا هذا
ليجيب امين عامي حلف الناتو ان عليهم ضمان
ان يكون لكييف جيشا اقوى بعد اي اتفاق
سلام فهل حان وقت السلام امنا مخازن
النيتو قد نفدت يعود ستارتنبر ويجيب قائلا
ان الحلف مستعد للانقراض في اي جهود دوليه
لبحث الضمانات الامنيه لاوكرانيا اي انه
مقتنع بالتفاوض مع موسكو وتوته خلصت
الحدوته كما يقولها السوريون هنا يواصل
حديثه مؤكدا ان امدادات الاسلحه الكبيره
التي قدمها حلف النيتو لاوكرانيا استنزفت
مخزونات من الذخائر لان استهلاك اوكرانيا
للذخائر يفوق وتيره انتاج الحلفين لها
بعده اضعاف حسب قوله وهو ما سيتطلب عامين
ونصف بدلا من عام واحد كما كان عليه الحال
في السابق فيا له من وضع صعب لاقوى حلف
عسكري في العالم ومن مخازن النيتو الى
مصانع الاسلحه البريطانيه وبعدما فتح رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشسوناك الباب امام
بريطانيا لارسال طائرات مقاتله الى
اوكرانيا هي لندن تخطط لخطوه اخرى قد
تجرهم نحو مواجهه مباشره مع موسكو وذلك
باستعداد البريطانيين لاقامه مشاريع
مشتركه مع كييف لتصنيع الاسلحه والمركبات
محليا بموجب ترخيص وذلك بحسب مجله
التلغراف فيما اعلن السفير الروسي في
بريطانيا اندري كلين ان بريطانيا تخطط
لمصادره الاصول الروسيه المجمده وتعد
تشريعا لذلك وفقا لوكاله نوفوستي لينتقل
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى العقوبات كرد على
الروس لكن هذه المره تم فرض عقوبات ضد
شركه شحن اماراتيه كجزء من حزمه العقوبات
العاشره ضد روسيا وذلك بزعم تخيلها على
العقوبات المفروضه ضد
ومن معارك العقوبات الى حرب الاستخبارات
وبعد ان نشر صحفي امريكي عن تورط واشنطن
بزرع متفجرات بخطوط انابيب الغاز بحسب
روترز خرجت المتحدثه الروسيه ماريا
وذلك بسبب تصريحاتها اللدعه لتطلق عليها
هذه التسميه فهي تعلن ان هناك حقائق كثيره
تتوفر بشان
وطالبت بعقد قمه طارئه لحلف شمال الاطلسي
لبحث الوضع فهل يستجيب الحلف لطلبها هنا
يظهر جيش بوتين الخفي وينفذ هجومه على حلف
النيتو حيث اعلن هاكرز من مجموعه انهم
اخترقوا الموقع الالكتروني لقياده حلف
النيتو الجويه في قاعده رمشتاين العسكريه
الامريكيه في المانيا الى حرب اخرى وخصم
اخر حيث صرح نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
بان روسيا سترد فورا في حال نشر اليابان
صواريخ فرط صوتيه على الجزر اليابانيه
بالقرب من الحدود الروسيه
اعلنت الخارجيه انا موسكو سترد على الفور
على اي تهديد لمناطق الشرق الاقصى الروسي
ما فيها نشر اليابان لصواريخ فرد صوتها
قرب الحدود الروسيه
اندلاع حرب البالونات ازمه المناطيد تتشعب
والولايات المتحده تدخل حربا مجهوله ستكون
الصين احد اطرافها لكن واشنطن لا تعلم
منهم الاعداء الاخرون لتعلن امريكا اغلاق
المجال الجوي فوق ولايه مونتانا بعد رصد
جسم مجهول في السماء قبل ان يتبين ان خللا
في الردار تسبب في الاغلاق بينما كانت
قياده الدفاع الجوي لامريكا الشماليه اكدت
ان طائرات مقاتله امري قد اسقطت جسما غير
معروف فوق بحيره هورن على الحدود مع كندا
بعد اسقاط جسم اخر فوق الاسكا ليصبح بذلك
رابعه جسم مجهول يتم اسقاطه فهل هناك عدو
اخر يهاجم الامريكان غير الصين الغموض
يكتنف هذه الاجسام الطائره وهنا تعلن بكين
ان جسما طائرا مجهول الهويه شوهد قباله
سواحل مقاطعه بشرق الصين وكان من الممكن
ان تسقطه السلطات المختصه وفق صحيفه
حرب البالونات تشتعل لتكسر بكين صمتها
وتعلن وزاره خارجيتها انه منذ العام
الماضي حلقت بالونات عاليه الارتفاع في
الولايات المتحده فوق الفضاء الجوي الصيني
دون اذن من الصين احدى عشره مره وفقا
لوكاله رويترز توترا البلدان على اثر قضيه
المنطاد وتم تعليق وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيين ليطفئ الامريكانو النار
بالوقود حيث ظهرت مجموعه القوه الضاربه
لحامله الطائرات
الثالثه عشره تقومان بعمليات استكشافيه
متكامله في بحر الصين الجنوبي بالتحركات
نشعله النار في صدور الصينيين اذن فكيف
سترد بكين رائحه الموت تعانق السماء ما
اقسى هذه اللحظات يمر الوقت ثقيلا كالجبال
على متضرري زلزال ورائحه الموت تنتشر في
كل مكان داخل الركام وتحت الانقاض عدد
ضحايا الزلزال يرتفع الى 36 الف قتيل في
سوريا وتركيا وبينما تمنح المانيا تاشيره
خاصه للمتضررين من السوريين والاتراك ها
هو منسق الامم
[موسيقى]
المجتمع الدولي لانقاذ حل الدولتين يا
سيدي الرئيس لماذا لا نقف مع فلسطين كما
وقف الغرب مع اوكرانيا وروسيا تحدد وجهتها
القادمه بعد اوكرانيا وبين الصين
والولايات المتحده حرب المناطيد والاجسام
الطائره ترعب الدولتين
[موسيقى]